[Music]
for the mothers in this room
yes yeah that was fast yep
uh how did you uh find out
what gender your baby was
when he started the ultrasound so you
found out in the hospital
yes you found out the hospital we found
out together yeah
oh oh yeah okay because i was thinking
like you did a gender reveal
but then you but we knew you knew it's
more for us that's boring
well some people they go with like their
best friend or whatever or a family
member
and then so uh they they do the
whatever and then they tell the family
members so they could do the general
reveal
party and then the parents stay outside
when did they start the technology to
the point where like
they can tell if they got a wiener or a
bp ultrasound
yeah now the technology isn't the most
um accurate yeah
oh we can get it wrong and then a girl
comes out yeah
you can the opposite happened to a
friend of mine she they told her she was
gonna have a girl
it turned out to be a boy why the doctor
so stupid yeah why is the doctor so
stupid and they end up buying a whole
bunch of like yeah [ __ ] and they're like
blue [ __ ] ton of pink stuff and then
luckily those stores
they like they were able to switch out
for like the other
gender yeah and the [ __ ] doctor again
like back in the day
it was just baby come out right yeah
yeah you just find out you're at the
farm house and it's like
all right it's a sun or it's a boy it's
like oh
[Music]
it's a boy oh like like the movies
and then they're like oh my god and then
the mommy's holding the baby that was
like the 1950s or something right or if
it's uh yeah i feel like
the 70s it was still like that it's a
boy
it's a girl it's true it was a boy where
it was like boy or abortion
oh what was that dictator what borat
yeah a girl was pregnant and he was like
oh congrats this is a boy or abortion oh
gee
[ __ ] was that i don't know it sound like
something he would say though that's so
funny it was so dark at the same time
but yeah
for your next babies would you guys want
to
do the whole gender reveal like at a
party and find out the gender
on the spot oh no but you didn't find
out yeah they they found out beforehand
i can't wait yeah we're too nosy you're
tuned out too you need to know
yeah for me i mean i really wanted to
like for the like the next kid but you
said no
you like surprises no no it's okay to
say oh
another one after that so i get whatever
no so this is what we talked about
for you guys so we had talked about like
the because we want to have two more
babies so then the first one yeah cause
we want them to grow up together except
like we feel really bad for isaac
growing up he's growing up as an only
child especially right now
yeah it's really hard it's really hard
for him anyway so
so then the first one um i was like oh
what if we just find out when the kid is
born and we buy
like everything like uh black white and
red
and then like the whole nursery and
stuff and you're like no i really want
to know so i'm like okay fine well then
the third one
we can do that maybe so i don't know
that's a lot of people yeah but yeah so
um so that that is a trend these days
with the whole like you know
gender reveal at the party the parents
find out then and there
you know when i was pregnant with isaac
that wasn't even a thing that wasn't a
thing it wasn't a thing that's crazy
that's gender reveal it's like brand new
when did it start after he's
12 years old so a few years after he was
born is when gender reveals started
being more popular
they do the baby showers yeah so there's
two parties now
gender reveal and then the baby's towers
combined it's combined usually done in
one now
but then i like because then it's like
the guests want to buy
presents for the kid but then you know
like for clothes or whatever usually
it's like
so what is it going to be yeah buy
everything yellow or green
right yes like this cake right here this
cake
is yellow so this is a story this is a
tick tock
about a mom who wanted to have that
gender reveal
uh but the baker she went to obviously
didn't understand the concept
of what a gender reveal party should be
like especially with the cake
and the color of the gender was going to
be revealed inside the cake and this is
what she got wait
that's that's how it works right yeah
but the baker doesn't know yeah the
color could be
it's supposed to be like blue or red or
something pink or something right this
is and this is what
happened to her i'm literally crying
over my nails right now
what will it be okay this
is what i wanted okay this is the
pastels
and this is what i got the cake just
gave it away
it's even it even says what will it be
on the cake but it's a [ __ ] blue cake
oh was that a baby at the top instead of
a beef
i don't know here here here's that close
that's hilarious
yeah there's even a baby at the top i
love that she's laughing
that's hilarious
i wonder i don't know they spelled
b like for like the insect oh yeah yeah
because the original one was b
that is and then because they had to be
stupid
the blue was probably supposed to be
inside the box yeah it's it's supposed
to be the icing inside the cake but they
put it on the outside that's the grand
finale that's such a like
baseball oh i want a [ __ ] cake man
i've been wanting a cake
so bad i thought you said cake i was
like oh cake party
no i wanted it that's how you should do
the jenna reveal like
you drink all of it but then it like
colors your tongue oh that'd be sick
super bad super bad you you mix in with
a little bit yeah
detergent detergent oh i was gonna give
laxatives with like
color so then every time they go to the
bathroom they'll see blue or red it's a
boy
and they're like red like it was red
it's like i was like i was like
oh it's a it's a girl and you're like
what like it's it's red
like oh i didn't give you the laxative
oh [ __ ]
it should be black then no that's
internal blue yeah
internal using black well that that'll
be hemorrhoids hemorrhoids yeah yeah
ladybug that's hemorrhoids or a lot of
watermelon green
or beets yeah oh beets oh babies there's
a lot of corn but i don't eat corn
then you've been sleep eating buddy
my mom wanted to keep one of my brothers
like when she was pregnant the secret
and so she told the ultrasound tech like
oh i don't want to know like
this one's a secret or whatever and then
the lady's like oh he's right there and
she's like
you know how i found out there's split
table oh so they're trying to
keep it a secret for me too right so
they're vlogging
in the uh we're stupid right yeah so
then bart's like he puts the camera down
when the guy
the nurse comes in and is talking to
them and he's like fiddling with the
remote trying to turn it off
and he goes oh like congrats on the boy
by the way so i hear that
but i think before that was they they
wanted to post a picture of the
ultrasound
um and i guess i [ __ ] up too because i
didn't see it but so they sent me the
picture that they wanted the thumbnail
to be
and then uh there's like a thumbnail oh
it said
on the also it has all the information
so it said
boy but they wrote boy in the
exclamation point oh i don't think it's
on a typical one but they want to be
like nice to them
so funny there was like a thousand
people that saw but then not everyone
caught on
oh no it wasn't a big deal funny
what if it was them saying boy it's a
girl
oh boy it's a girl everyone did the same
motion
oh boy it's a girl that's how we should
end every jk news
i want a coconut cake you know the cheap
ones that you could get at ralph's
it's just a cake with the coconut
frosting
it's good i started getting sushi around
the ones that's been out why would you
do that
is it nasty fake crab one death wish
what fake crab one
that one's pretty good really really
good and it's just big crab good the
fancy looking [ __ ] i don't get i just
get the negative
sushi like the basic [ __ ] oh that no
that's the fancy stuff
i get the one that's just the roll
that's the fake crap so there's no fish
in it oh i guess it's fancy because it's
like it takes more effort it seems like
to get one of those things done
but yeah i hear you what's another cool
way of revealing it because
i watched this one video of this couple
that we're trying to like they both had
a bat and they're trying to break the
balloon
to do the gender reveal but then they
kept hitting it wouldn't pop and then it
flew away
like the ones where the kids like they
have more than one kid
and then the first kid uh like he'll
ruin it like by either popping the
balloon ahead of time or do you see that
next camera one
no so the mom was walking out gonna
drive to the party and then the little
kid and she has a balloon with her
the little bastard kid comes up and runs
and pops and you just see the moms just
are like
and just like start crying i think a
good one
is um you get uh actors to be a swat
team
they break into your baby shower and
then they shoot you up and then
everything that flies out is like blue
or pink did you see that
kind of cool
and it's blue i liked how how christina
surprised aunt with leia how
she like she put pink powder in his
his blow dryer and then he started using
it was like pink everywhere
no that's was he like oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
wonder if it blinds him remember his
gender revealed that [ __ ] was smoking up
the whole thing and it wouldn't stop
and we're like oh [ __ ] yeah the second
one
i know that was intense i was like this
is what the shit's like
like everyone's faces were like tiny
like i think that turned into a fail
don't think it was supposed to smoke
that hard
that's true it was intense we had a
bunch of the smoke then you should have
one
i know it looked cool did it make it
look cool i thought it was pretty good i
thought that was pretty cool
you wanted to make sure dude i haven't
even like held them and seen enzo yet
what yeah because as so they had
enzo um and i think i was in europe the
first time
well they've also been super safe and
now yeah they were safe and then i went
back to europe and when i came back i
was in quarantino
for like months right right but i went
to his house actually to get
uh avocados avocados so i saw him
through the window
but it's crazy man and everything enzo's
a
a friend's kid by the way so people that
don't oh that's baby yeah yeah all right
mm-hmm how would you want to find out
i don't know there's some film [ __ ] huh
yeah let's make it [ __ ]
epic because sometimes i try probe
cameras
i think about it too because i've asked
you like if we ever
do get pregnant would you want to find
out the same time i find out so like
together or would you want me to
surprise you and you said you want to
find out with me so i'm like okay
but before that both of you guys could
be surprised too yeah but like
something something to surprise him oh
like because you know there's always
always those like cute videos of like
like there's like a bun literally in the
oven and like oh what do i have in the
oven that's so overdone though
no i know that's basic as hell i saw
like the cutest video ever where the the
wife surprised my dad
[Laughter]
right and there was uh three babies and
then the guy was like so confused and he
kept counting them and he's like
it's like what and she was he was just
three and he goes she goes yeah
he goes wait like one two three and he's
like
yeah and he's like starts freaking out
he's like so ultrasound picture yeah
those are super cute dude i saw one that
i [ __ ] loved so it was um
they had uh like four girls already on
at a table and they did the cupcake
um and that was that's how the wife was
gonna reveal it to the husband he's
sitting at the head of the table
all the kids are eating or the girls
because he had four girls
uh so they're eating their cupcakes and
then as soon as they bite into it
they're like
oh it's pink and you just see the dad
get up and he like walks out and he just
[ __ ] flops
into the swimming pool because he's like
he's been wanting a boy because he's
hoping his fifth one was going to be a
boy finally
all girls all girls and he was like
hoping that this was going to be a boy
and then he
saw it he didn't say [ __ ] he just put it
down and walked out that's funny
but the cookie my cousin has that so the
whole family is
all girls so it's just he's the only guy
yeah yeah
he's been trying trying trying again
he's going to get taken care of like
crazy though that's what i'm saying
bro dude nobody wants to go yeah when
they're all older i gotta wait hello
long yeah but no i mean like only like
20 years yeah i mean it's it's very
noisy i think but at the same time
what do you mean joe have you ever had a
boy as a child
well it's a different kind of noise
right like they're destructive oh like a
pleasant noise i got you
huh he's like sure
but i feel like when when the guys get
older
they'll just be like i'm in my own
family i'm not gonna [ __ ] talk to you
yeah like the daughters are like always
coming back my brother's the opposite
my brother always takes care of my mama
alright cool i guess that there's a good
example then
[Music]
you